la peur du frigo vide au delà du
prolongement possible du pass sanitaire
jusqu'à l'été prochain ou encore de
l'extension confirmé de celui ci aux
adolescents de 12 à 17 ans un autre
sujet d'inquiétude et ce samedi sur les
lèvres des manifestants anti passe la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat je pense qu'il
va se greffer autre chose que le pass
and iter le pouvoir d'achat générale
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation des retraites faux pas
qui tire trop sur la ficelle parce que
ça va casser les jeunes là on va les
revoir à toulouse à lille c'est le même
leitmotiv
beaucoup se demandent comment boucler
les fins de mois notamment avec
l'annoncé récente de la hausse des
tarifs énergétiques entre 12 et 15,8
pour cent pour le carburant depuis le
début de l'année 12,6 pour cent pour le
gaz au 1er octobre
sans oublier l'augmentation prévue de
12% de l'électricité en janvier prochain
ou encore celles liées aux produits de
première nécessité de portefeuille se
vide et la colère elle grandit la manif
d'aujourd'hui à l'est aussi pour le
pouvoir d'achat également parce que je
suis il est jeune et
on a une augmentation comme de 50 % du
gaz on a longuement tation de l'essence
également là on va peut être arriver à
deux euros le litre un truc de fou ils
sont en train de dépouiller nous revenus
ils augmentent légèrement légèrement
j'ai vu là le salaire le salaire moyen
il a augmenté de +0 26% et paris ne fait
pas exception là encore la hausse du gaz
ne passe pas l'augmentation du gaz en
fin d'année sera de plus de 50 % sur un
an on vit dans quel pays est ce que ces
choses là ne sont pas encadrées
normalement par les gouvernements et des
mesures comment on peut avoir une
augmentation de plus de 50% en un an et
que le gouvernement ne lève pas le petit
doigt c'est incroyable en prévision de
ces manifestations jean castex a pris
les devants invité ce jeudi dans le 20
heures de tf1 le premier ministre a
annoncé un bouclier tarifaire plusieurs
mesures pour atténuer l'augmentation des
prix on nous prévoit d'ici la fin de
l'année 30% à nouveau d'augmentation du
prix du gaz nous allons bloquer les prix
du gaz il n'y aura plus d'augmentation
nous empêcherons la hausse en réduisant
le montant d'une taxe sur l'électricité
nous limiterons cette hausse à 4% début
février aucune mesure en revanche
concernant la hausse des carburants le
premier ministre s'est dit toutefois
attentifs à la situation fin 2010 8 sél
annonce de l'augmentation du prix à la
pompe qui avait déclenché le mouvement
des gilet jaune